we have a little surprise for you 20th
anniversary a little reflection here we
have a throwback interview we also have
something yeah I've always always always
wanted to be a singer and now it's like
I'm really doing it I didn't do my first
music video I was coming out and ah guys
I'm psyched I'm still doing the same
stuff some things never change
oh my gosh yes it's it's like baby me
it's almost like looking at my daughter
yeah it's very interesting um but yeah I
mean it's looking back at that it's
interesting because she realized how
long you've been working and even before
that with the Mickey Mouse Club and I
mean it's it's my whole my whole life so
it's a very interesting reflective sort
of cosmic you know aligning thing to be
accepting this award 2020 of album Mulan
soundtrack it's just a beautiful
beautiful time so now when we say we
stand a legend legend to the moment oh
my god yes I mean it's it's it's what's
been a part of my career forever as a
child with the Mickey Mouse Club and
being alongside amazing talent there it
was the first time I felt like I was
home in amongst you know other kids who
loved doing the same you know who loved
perform who loved to use their
imagination and it was such a amazing
place of creativity and fun and laughs
and it was it was a place where you
truly where I truly felt accepted for
the first time so Disney I think has has
done that for so many people whether
it's cozying on your couch or working
for them it's just such a great escape
and I think that's why I'm so I'm so
honored to be a part of something so
legendary and just so incredible to be a
part of the family I want to get a
little bit reflective pun intended
because it is the 20th anniversary of
your debut album
I auditioned with the song reflection
and koa to coincide getting my first
record deal and tomorrow yeah it's it's
the the 20th anniversary of the debut
album and the Milan soundtrack and the
fact that I sang reflection which
jump-started everything getting my foot
in the door it's so weird and awkward
that footage would it's so cute and so
amazing to see such you know the just to
look back and see the growth in your
life in your career and in yourself
it's just it's just a great day
[Music]